[Music]
the new movie crazy rich Asians had big
expectations when it opened last week it
did even better than forecast the
romantic comedy was number one at the
weekend box office in North America
Warner Brothers estimates that it made
thirty four million dollars in ticket
sales since Wednesday but the movie is
all Asian cast an Asian director Jon M
Chu could be the studio's biggest payoff
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn shows how the movie is
being celebrated as a turning point for
asian american representation in
hollywood glad it's about time good
morning glad it is about time good
morning it's been a quarter century
since a nearly all Asian cast starred in
a Hollywood studio film that was 1993 s
The Joy Luck Club and while some critics
say crazy rich Asians doesn't do enough
to improve diversity in Hollywood most
agree it's a step in the right direction
these people aren't just rich
okay they're crazy rich crazy rich
Asians may not be the solution to all of
Hollywood's diversity problems but fans
like David Chen believe it can help I
asked myself like well what am i doing
to further the cause of diversity and
more representation on screen Shen is
one of several people who have bought
out showings even entire cinemas to get
people to see the film he says he was
inspired by the movie's director John
Chu who passed on a big payday with
Netflix to get crazy rich Asians in
theaters we didn't need the money we
didn't we had an agenda to get this to
the most eyeballs but but at a place
that it could affect the most people
Hollywood has struggled with Asian
American representation the industry was
recently ridiculed for casting white
actors in roles seemingly intended for
Asian actors my dad was a Chinese
wine and my mother Swedish after a while
I think Hollywood got scared
Kimberly um is the Asian voices editor
for HuffPost in a series of widely
shared tweets she described the movies
emotional impact after growing up Asian
American there were just so many
different types of Asians we were just
ourselves authentically Asia for someone
who has never seen that that meant a lot
and while Yama says crazy rich Asians
does sacrifice some cultural accuracy
she says the film makes up for it in the
name of fun hopefully more stories will
be made of different experiences both in
the asian-american community along with
other minorities earlier this summer
box-office experts predict that crazy
rich Asians would open up with just half
of the estimated thirty four million
dollars the movies made in its first
five days the film is helping raise the
success of Hollywood summer season
revenue is up more than 12 percent over
last summer oh I'd like to hear that
after all the really good reviews I'm
dying to see this movie I'm seeing it
this weekend as well yeah I mean movies
like this and black panther and get out
it's only a good thing probably wouldn't
buy Klansmen for sure alright fine thank
you